So there's this movie that just came out called Wonder Park.
In January 2018 the director of Wonder Park was
fired for allegedly sexually harassing co-workers, and rather than just hire a competent director, or even
another director to replace him, the producers
opted to just not do that.
Now, for animated film, this isn't
super strange. I mean, it's it's a little strange but it isn't incomprehensible.
Animated movies are basically made in slow motion. So it's entirely possible for a movie to be
basically at a point where the movie is kind of done long before it's actually finished.
Like the movie's been storyboarded, and the animatics are done, and all the voice work is done.
And there's even basically a rough edit of the film, and now it's just in the slow grueling process of actually finishing it.
At that point, the creative leads can pretty much just be left to their own devices to figure it out themselves.
They're probably all, you know, competent, creative individuals who are capable of, like,
solving problems and making decisions and reaching a consensus, and if they do hit any sort of
creative impassable roadblock where some executive decision needs to be made, well,
you know, the producers are still there and that is literally the producer's job.
So you get to the end of Action Park and
there's no director credit. Like, it's not left blank. It's just, it's not there at all.
It is entirely absent.
That said, it's super obvious that Wonder Park is a movie with no credited director,
because the big thing it lacks is direction.
It is, in a word insubstantial.
If you took My Neighbor Totoro and Inside Out and the prologue of Up,
and you just took those movies and you stuck them in a blender, and you
liquefied them, and then you took that and
dumped it into a swimming pool, and then you took an eyedropper of the pool water,
that would be this movie. This movie is the homeopathic version of
Inside Out. Now before going into it,
I heard that this movie was gonna be, like, right up my alley, that it was yet another movie that attempts to mix
childish whimsy with grim, heavy story, and boy was I disappointed.
I actually watched A Monster Calls a few hours earlier in preparation, just to like,
calibrate my internal instruments.
And it turned out, it wasn't needed because there is nothing there.
A Monster Calls, if you're not familiar with it, is a 2016 drama about a boy
who retreats into fantasy to try and cope with his mother's terminal cancer.
It's a beautiful film and it's gut-wrenching.
It's a really complex and nuanced story about confronting death
and the way that stories and fantasies can be a distraction from facing reality,
but they can also be a huge aid in helping us
process difficult emotions in helping us rationalize
complicated things like grief and anger and guilt.
Fantasy films about kids dealing with sick or dying parents is actually a whole sub-genre unto itself.
For your older teens and adults you've got I Kill Giants, for your tweens and up
you've got A Monster Calls, and for all ages, there's My Neighbor Totoro.
Wonder Park is technically the
same genre, but only
Technically there is a mom who gets sick and needs to go away
so she does and
Then she's back at the end and the rest of the movie just kind of happens
In between those two points, like there's a lot of disconnected prom here. So
let's make a list 1 the setup is
overly complicated so the setup is that this young girl Jun and her mom
create Wonderland as a
collaborative bedtime story with Jun stuffed animals filling the role of
Mascot staff and hosts her stuffed monkey peanut is the Mickey Mouse type ringleader who?
magics the rides into existence and yes
I said Wonderland the park in wonder park is called Wonderland and they repeat this over and over
you are the Wonder in Wonderland in the interior fiction of Wonderland peanut is the
creator who manifests Wonderland via
ideas that he receives
Whispered on the wind when Jun's mom
whispers Jun's ideas into the stuffed animal peanuts ear look
I know it's a lot of steps, but they spend a lot of time in the movie itself
Negotiating the process because after mom gets sick and goes away
It's the fact that Jun doesn't feel right whispering ideas into peanuts ear
That's the thing that causes her to abandon Wonderland
backing up a bit before Jun's mom gets sick Jun actually builds a makeshift roller coaster in the backyard out of
fencing and a wagon and
The the ensuing chaos ends up
Demolishing a bunch of the neighborhood and almost gets Jun killed
so
after that
Jun and her mother start building Wonderland as clockwork miniatures that this this sprawling
clockwork miniature that ends up taking over most of the house
So then June's mom gets sick and has to go away for treatment and Jun packs up a Wonderland and becomes
Overly protective of her dad and his health and at this point the movie still isn't done
setting up because dad then sends Jun off to math camp but on her way there she
Like has a panic attack. She she imagines this scenario where her dad is going to like
Eat pizza and drink beer all summer and get fat and lazy and if he doesn't have a heart attack
He's going to light the house on fire or explode or something. So she
Imagines this elaborate scenario and convinces herself that she needs to go home. And so she
Creates a
catastrophe on the bus forcing the bus to stop and giving her an opportunity to sneak away and
And take the hiking trails
Back home, then finally as she's walking through the forest
She comes across the magical abandoned ruins of Wonderland and the movie properly starts
So Wonderland as she finds it is in disrepair because she stopped imagining it
So she needs to rekindle her imagination and fix the park to save it from the darkness
All right issue two, the character designs are boring
so the fantasy Wonderland is staffed with magical talking versions of June's stuffed animals, but these characters are
Really unmemorable in their designs both in terms of being characters in a Nickelodeon film that will no doubt lean
heavily on merchandising and
Also in terms of being the mascots of a fictional theme park
the only one that has any Flair is boomer the bear who is blue and
That's it. He's still otherwise just a bear
But he's blue
Otherwise, they're all just generic cartoon animals three the camera work is chaos
The three things that this movie really loves are extreme high angles
extreme wide-angle lenses that are super close-up and
completely unmotivated movement that just
spins
Everywhere it's the kind of shot that animators like to block because it's complicated and it gives them a chance to show off but then
It happens so often and it's so repetitive that it starts to feel like showing
Like it happens often enough that it's calling attention to itself and it starts to feel almost like the director was fired
and then the animators were just left to their own devices without direction for a year for
The main conflict isn't really the main conflict
It's actually really unfair to compare this movie to something like a monster calls because it's not really about
June
Dealing with her mother's illness
June's mother's illness isn't the thing that the movie is about. It's just the thing that happens after
the start of the movie but before
the rest of the movie the conflict in Wonderland doesn't really have anything to do with it or
How June is handling it really? The story is a post-apocalyptic
Action-adventure zombie movie in a decrepit theme park then tacked on to that you have a token ill-defined
generic sort of
Don't let the spark of creativity die
type message to
Kinda tie it all together
So Wonderland is being devoured by the darkness a storm cloud
vortex hovering over the park that has infected the parks signature toys turning them into an army of
chimpanzees that are demolishing the park and taking the wreckage and and
hurling it up into
the vortex of the darkness
Jun defeats the darkness when she finds the personal will to whisper ideas
Into Peanuts ear allowing him to then
manifest them into the world of
Wonderland and they use that to then turn on the park again so that they can just
Reset everything, but then there's still a small
remnant of the darkness hanging over the park of all the movies Wonder Park wants to be it wants most of all to be
Inside out. So that's why you have this weak nod to the idea
That being sad isn't always a bad thing five
This is just the setup for the TV show
That's the reason any of this exists and it's also the reason it
Exists the way that it exists the movie doesn't really matter
It's just laying the foundation for the Nickelodeon series that is already in production
and that's why the setup is so complicated and also so
Insubstantial they're just they're just seeding ideas that they can come back to in the TV show
It's also probably why the characters are so bland the animals are really simple and basic
Specifically so that the models will play nice in a simplified television rendering pipeline
It's also why June doesn't really need to deal with any meaningful character growth beyond
Establishing the perpetuity of Wonderland is why they didn't bother
Replacing the director. It doesn't matter. The movie was always just the precursor to the TV show
So it doesn't need to be good or coherent it just needs to
Exist, even the cloud of darkness lingering in Wonderland at the end feels less like a meaningful
Resolution and more like a plot seed like all right
Here's our antagonists generator that show writers can use whenever they need to explain. Why something in
Wonderland is broken or misbehaving funny enough. This is actually kind of the opposite of those movies like
where a monster calls and I kill Giants and
to really the sort of magical realism of
my neighbor totoro are are
about people
Retreating into fantasy in order to deal with or cope with or rationalize something in their life
but in wonder Park June doesn't
Retreat into fantasy to deal with her mother's illness. It's the opposite. She rejects fantasy and
becomes too practical
and
needs to
Rediscover
imagination
But she doesn't need to rediscover imagination to cope with her mother's illness. It's she just needs to
rediscover imagination because her sadness is
Eating the park for the purpose of the film. It doesn't really matter. Why
June is sad and the validity of that is never explored like mom's illness could have been replaced with
Anything it doesn't matter that she's sick. We don't address the fact that she's sick and how June
relates to that how she
Processes it all that matters is that there is an interruption of some kind so the validity of June's
Sadness, it's just it's not it's not brought up at all. In fact, it's so not relevant that the animals
blame June for wrecking the park because she created the darkness and the movie is just like
Yeah, you know what? It is kind of her fault for getting sad
She should have thought about how her sadness would make other people feel
Which I don't know about you, but that's a great message for children